ondes le burundi fait partie des 45 pays
ou action contre la faim intervient
benoît thevenet philippe tu reposes sont
allées dans ce pays africains pour mieux
se rendre compte de la situation très
difficile des enfants dans ce pays elle
vit quelque part au milieu de ces
collines comme des milliers d'autres
enfants la petite concilie meurent de
faim la fillette ne sourit plus ne
pleure plus elle survit accompagnée de
son père concilie vient d'arriver dans
un centre de lutte contre la
malnutrition
mon enfant afin avec nos toute petite
terre on ne peut avoir qu'une sorte de
culture ma fille souffre de carences et
puis il ya la guerre parfois on est
obligé de s'enfuir plusieurs jours dans
la brousse et tout cela ne fait
qu'aggraver le problème
à 4 ans concilie pèse 10 kg elle n'a
donc aucun mal à être admise au centre
d'action contre la faim
une première auscultation permet
d'identifier d'éventuelles pathologies
puis elle reçoit une batterie de
traitement vitamines anti paludéens
antibiotiques pendant ce temps son père
met à jour ses connaissances en matière
d'hygiène et je continuais à leur
sensibilité sur l'hygiène corporelle
vestimentaire et sans oublier les jeunes
des deux côtés
quand il
comment donc vous en prendrez volé au
burundi la malnutrition est chronique au
rythme des déplacements de populations
engendrée par la guerre au rythme des
épidémies de paludisme 300 à 500
personnes passent ici chaque mois
concilier son père vont s'installer dans
cette pièce pour une semaine épuisés ils
vont comme les autres restés longtemps
silencieux l'urgence est de remettre en
marche leur organisme est de faire
diminuer les oedèmes qui ont envahi les
jambes à cause des carences en protéines
l'enfant ne prend pas de poids en phase
on va juste surveillé la reprise de
l'appétit
la diminution des oedèmes et que
l'enfant n'est plus de problèmes
pathologiques aiguë sévère
changement d'atmosphère dans cette
partie du temps les bénéficiaires comme
on les appelle ici vont rester trois
semaines le lait enrichi va leur
permettre de reprendre du poids et jour
après jour les enfants et leurs parents
change de physionomie
les sourires reviennent et les pleurs
dossier
je suis content parce que mon enfant va
mieux il a bien récupéré et les oedèmes
a presque disparu au cours de leur
séjour à kayanza les enfants comme
concilie grossiront d'environ 3 kg face
à la prochaine épidémie ou mauvaises
récoltes
ils résisteront mieux mais combien de
temps